estamos ya en el problema 53 y dice
arturo está tratando de resolver esta
ecuación completando el cuadrado y nos
dan la ecuación a x cuadrada más bx más
c igual a 0 donde el término a es
positivo entonces nos dan varios pasos
paso 1 me dice a x cuadrada más bx igual
a menos c esencialmente lo que hizo es
restar se de ambos lados de esta
ecuación para que se cancele esta se nos
quede se del otro lado pero con signo
negativo luego al siguiente paso lo que
hizo fue dividir entre a por eso es
necesario pedirle que al menos no sea
cero verdad entonces al hacer el paso 2
divide entre a y nos quedó x cuadrada
más b sobre x igual a menos sobre a todo
lo anterior lo dividió sobre a y el paso
3 no lo tenemos la pregunta es cuál
debería ser el paso 3 en la solución y
en esencialmente todo esto ya lo hemos
visto en otros vídeos donde hablábamos
de cómo completar él
el trinomio cuadrado perfecto para poder
deducir la ecuación o la fórmula
cuadrática pero bueno vamos a irlo
haciendo tenemos x cuadrada + b sobre a
x y vamos a tener si queremos resolver
la ecuación completando el cuadrado
tenemos que sumar algo y que nos va a
dar menos el sobre a y vamos a sumar s
eso mismo que sumemos del lado izquierdo
entonces ya lo hemos visto en unos
vídeos atrás
tenemos esencialmente que agregar la
mitad de este número que tengo aquí que
es de entre a y elevarlo al cuadrado lo
elevamos al cuadrado y eso es lo que
vamos a sumar de ambos lados si no sabes
de qué estoy hablando quizás debería ser
buena idea que veas el vídeo de cómo
completar los cuadrados o el trinomio
cuadrado perfecto entonces tienes la
mitad debe entre a tenemos la mitad de
ver sobre a y esto pues no es otra cosa
más que ver entre dos a así que lo que
tenemos que agregar tenemos que poner
todo igual x
ve sobre x x y agregamos b sobre 2 a al
cuadrado y eso si lo agrego del lado
izquierdo lo tengo que agregar también
aquí del lado derecho para que la
igualdad se conserve entonces vamos a
ver si con esta expresión ya tenemos la
solución y si esta verdad es justo la
opción de la opción de es justo esto que
escribí aquí entonces igual y de igual
forma si no tuvo mucho sentido esto que
hicimos para ti entonces sería bueno que
veas el vídeo de cómo completar el
cuadrado vamos al ejercicio 54 que
entonces nos dan cuatro pasos para
deducir la fórmula cuadrática aunque y
se muestran aquí abajo y nos preguntan
cuál es el orden correcto de estos pasos
y si te das cuenta varios pasos ya los
hicimos acá arriba acá arriba tenemos
este primer paso y luego este segundo
paso vamos a ver y si los tenemos verdad
este sería nuestro primer paso
este es nuestro primer paso aquí fue el
primero que realizamos o bueno de los
primeros que realizamos verdad primero
se resta se y luego se divide todo entre
a y obtenemos este resultado
en nuestro primer paso y después qué fue
lo que hicimos después sumamos lo que me
va a completar el trinomio cuadrado
perfecto que está de este lado es el 4
entonces primero es el paso 1 y luego es
el paso 4 y ahora qué es lo que sigue
bueno pues tenemos que notar que esto de
la izquierda es un binomio al cuadrado y
cuál binomio al cuadrado pues el que
tiene x más este término y todo eso al
cuadrado es decir justo como acá y del
lado derecho simplemente es simplificar
esto verdad aquí si desarrollamos esto
es b cuadrada entre 4 a cuadrada y
podemos sacar de común denominador 4 al
cuadrado se resuelve esto y
simplificamos y llegamos a esto verdad
entonces esta sería mi me paso 3 ya no
los voy a enmarcar ok el paso el
siguiente paso es el 2 y bueno pues ya
nada más nos queda el paso 3 verdad que
es
y sacar la raíz cuadrada sacamos la raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados y después
restamos de entre 2 a para despejar x
entonces vamos a ver si esta secuencia
de paso se encuentra en nuestras
opciones y es 1 423 a justo es el inciso
a 1 423 eso estuvo bastante bien ok y
bueno ya hemos dicho que se puede
deducir la fórmula completando la
fórmula cuadrática completando el
binomio el trinomio cuadrado perfecto
verdad así que esto simplemente es hacer
ejercicios de eso mismo
nos preguntan cuál es una solución de la
ecuación 2x cuadrada menos x 4 igual a 0
entonces si nos damos cuenta en las
opciones se ve que no vamos a poder
factorizar así que pues vamos a utilizar
la fórmula cuadrática y realmente la
fórmula cuadrática y si tenemos a x
cuadrada más bx más se igual a cero
entonces la solución está dada está dada
como que este es un polinomio en general
verdad un polinomio de segundo grado el
que sea a b y c pues los tenemos que
ajustar nuestro caso particular pero la
solución está dada como menos b más
menos la raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada
menos 4 hace todo esto sobre 2 y muy
bien entonces simplemente hay que notar
que b es menos uno a es 2 y c es menos
cuatro así que si tomamos este caso
particular tenemos que ver es menos 1
así que tenemos menos menos
uno más menos la raíz de menos uno al
cuadrado menos cuatro por a que en este
caso es 24 por dos por sé que es menos
cuatro menos cuatro y todo eso lo
dividimos entre dos a que es 2 por 2 ya
de una vez voy a ponerlo como 4 muy bien
y esto simplemente es uno más menos la
raíz de uno al cuadrado bueno aquí
tenemos menos 4 por 2 es menos 8 por
menos 4 son 32 y si le sumamos menos 1
al cuadrado que es 1 entonces tenemos la
raíz de 33 todo esto todo eso sobre 4
así que vamos a ver si alguna de estas
soluciones se encuentra ya en nuestra
lista y si si ésta está aquí verdad es
la opción c 1 más la raíz de 33 sobre 4
si quisiéramos la otra es ponerle aquí
un menos
vámonos con un ejercicio más 56 cuál de
las siguientes afirmaciones explica
mejor porque no hay soluciones reales a
la ecuación cuadrática 2x cuadrada más x
más 7 igual a cero entonces voy a poner
nuevamente la fórmula cuadrática es
menos b más menos la raíz de cuadrada
menos 4 hace está ya para estas alturas
de la deberías de memorizar porque le
estamos usando mucho y si nos damos
cuenta la única forma para no tener
soluciones es o sea todo está bien
definido todo está muy bien definido
excepto cuando lo que hay dentro de la
raíz cuadrada es negativo y eso es
porque no podemos sacar raíces cuadradas
de números negativos así que cuando no
hay solución cuando b cuadrada menos 4
ac es menor que cero es negativo ahí es
donde se presentan todos los problemas
vamos a ver qué pasa en este en este
ejemplo tenemos
aquí sería de cuadrada en este caso es 1
al cuadrado menos 4 que multiplica a que
es 2 y luego multiplicarse que es 7 y
necesitamos que esto sea negativo
entonces de las opciones que nos dan me
dice que puede s ese valor de hecho aquí
bueno 11 al cuadrado es lo mismo verdad
entonces 1 al cuadrado menos o al
cuadrado 1 menos 4 por 2 por 7 debe ser
negativo esa es la opción
correspondiente a que no haya soluciones
reales verdad a menos de que nos
saltemos al conjunto de los números
imaginarios pero ya ese es otro tema
entonces al menos en los números reales
no hay soluciones cuando este número es
negativo
ok así que yo creo que podemos irnos a
un último ejercicio dice cuál es el
conjunto solución de la ecuación
cuadrática 8x cuadrada más 2 x más 1
igual a 0 entonces yo creo que vamos a
usar de una vez
la fórmula cuadrática directamente
entonces es menos b que es menos 2
más menos la raíz de b cuadrada que es 2
al cuadrado si es los al cuadrado menos
44 por a que es 8 x sé que es 1 y creo
que lo estoy haciendo creo que sí está
bien entonces esto va sobre 2 x a que es
2 por 8 entonces si esto lo
desarrollamos esto es menos 2 más menos
la raíz de 4 menos 4 por 8 32 y creo que
está bien hasta este momento sobre 2 por
8 que son 16 y bueno si ya terminamos
esto ya podrás ver que hay problemas
verdad porque aquí sacamos la raíz de 4
menos 32 que son menos 28 sobre 16 sobre
16 entonces tenemos un problema severo
porque tenemos la raíz de un número
negativo entonces la única forma de
tener raíces negativas es si nos salimos
del conjunto de los números reales y eso
hasta este
no lo estamos permitiendo entonces la
solución o más bien la respuesta es que
el conjunto solución es vacío no hay
soluciones reales yo la verdad al inicio
creí que nos habíamos equivocado pero
pero no la respuesta es que no hay
soluciones reales ok entonces no podemos
tomar raíces cuadradas de números
negativos y seguir siendo todavía un
número real la verde amos habrá tiempo
para otro más no mejor nos esperamos al
siguiente vídeo nos vemos pronto